okay wait wait wait wait if you're
watching on youtube
and you've shown up to troll before
hitting dislike and leaving a negative
nasty comment consider watching the
video first
okay i was really surprised over the
weekend people started sending me links
to a tweet
that jordan peterson sent out saying
david you've got to talk about this dumb
thing that jordan peterson said and i
presumed it would be some kind of
esoteric
nuance statement which could be
interpreted ten different ways or
i'd critique it and his followers would
say no david you're misunderstanding
what he said or
that's not what he meant or you just
don't have the capacity to know what
he's really talking about
but then i saw the tweet and i started
to wonder whether something was wrong
because this is bizarre even for jordan
peterson and i'm going to explain this
entire thing to you
and if you haven't heard of jordan
peterson he's a psychologist
and sort of self-help dude whose
teachings have really resonated with
many young men around
the world he came to prominence for his
opposition to a bill in canada
which he said would threaten to jail
people for using the wrong gender
pronouns which of course was never true
and uh peterson suggested that
misgendering people
or using the wrong pronouns could be
considered hate speech which
could conceivably get you jail time but
of course misgendering people
has never been considered hate speech by
canadian courts canadian courts have a
really
high threshold for what counts as hate
speech but the entire thing worked
really well for peterson to build him
a big following so he's he's doing very
well
so anyway over the weekend jordan
peterson tweeted positive comments about
a guy named bjorn
lomborg for our discussion today you
don't have to know anything
about lomborg because what matters is
what peterson said about him
which was via twitter that quote he's
casually called
a climate change denier for example
which is an appallingly treacherous term
of criticism
used to denigrate someone personally by
associating them with
holocaust deniers the ethics of
anyone who employs it should be
instantly
questioned so layer one is that
in no way does calling someone a climate
change denier
implies reference that they're in any
way like holocaust deniers i mean just
it in no way whatsoever contrary
to peterson's own views he seems to have
been
triggered by innocuous language climate
denier
and he's trying to police language
such that those whose views on climate
change they're not based on science
are not called deniers anymore and then
he's
also virtue signaling by calling into
question the ethics of anyone who uses
the term climate change denier
i look around i looked hard and there's
no evidence whatsoever
anywhere that the term climate denier is
deliberately or even by sheer
consequence
referencing or implying anything like
holocaust denial
peterson is arguing that calling people
deniers of things
is effectively an ad hominem looking to
associate them
with people who deny the holocaust i
mean it's patently patently ludicrous
and absurd
climate change the latest neo-marxist
post-modernist plot which is absolutely
destroying the lives of young men
everywhere by questioning the
archetypes of dominant hierarchy i'm
sorry
dominant hierarchies i guess i need to
reset i went into jordan peterson
talking point coma there so that's layer
one okay i mean truly just a dumb thing
to say
but here's where it gets even better in
2016
peterson tweeted that you that a
university of toronto professor
is a biological sex denier
saying quote you toronto prof
a biological sex denier
on canadian public television with me
jordan peterson absolutely obliterates
jordan peterson right he is now claiming
that the phraseology of x denier
insert here denier is an ad hominem
meant to link people to holocaust denial
and he did
the exact same thing when he called the
university of toronto professor
a biological sex denier
how do people listen to this guy i mean
truly picking and choosing
when to be offended going against his
own stated principles but more
importantly
saying really silly things like calling
someone a climate change denier when
that's what they're doing they're
denying the overwhelming established
science on climate change is like
likening someone
to a holocaust denier and actually pat
many people in our audience may not know
but aside from his self-help
ideas peterson has become a pretty
stalwart climate science denier
huh that's pretty interesting um you
know when you listen to jordan peterson
speak
he often talks very slowly he takes
these long pauses and you get the
impression that he really wants
to formulate his ideas and make sure
that he's communicating clearly
and yet he seems to routinely have
gaffes like these like when he talks
about enforced monogamy
or i don't know many many different
examples climate change denial
all this stuff you wouldn't suspect that
for someone who
chooses his word so carefully and yet
peterson uh repeatedly makes gaffes like
these
yes and here is another one and if
anyone wants to defend this by all means
i'm ready to hear from you and
uh it is not just because he
uh is on on the right that i am talking
about him i
also talk about people on the left who
say things that don't make sense and
that's exactly what i'm going to do next
talking about alexandria ocasio-cortez
so i think everybody's going to end up
upset with me because of this segment